مياه اضافيه مقابل التنسيق ضد تواجد حزب
العمال الكردستاني في العراق عرض مشروط تم
التوصل اليه لاتفاق حوله وعاد رئيس
الوزراء العراقي محمد شاع السوداني قادما
من تركيا فخلال زيارته الى انقره اعلن
السوداني انه حصل على ما يريده العراق
طبعا من كميات اضافيه من المياه المتدفقه
من تركيا الى نهري دجله والفرات وان كانت
تلك الكميات محدوده الا انها مكسب وفق
الوصف الحكومي بالعراق خصوصا بعدما عاشت
البلاد سنوات من الجفاف رئيس الوزراء
العراقيه محمد شياع السوداني اعتبر اعلان
الرئيس التركي حول زياده تدفقات المياه
نجاح لتوجهات الحكومه مؤكدا في ذات الوقت
انه يعمل على تامين حصص العراق من حقه في
المياه عبر الحوارات هذا ابرز ما حصل عليه
السوداني خلال زيارته
المشاهدينا ما الذي قدمه مقابل هذا العرض
المحدود قال هنا اعلام تركي ان السوداني
قدم ضمانات على ان يصنف العراق حزب العمال
الكردستاني منظمه ارهابيه والتنسيق
المشترك على طرد المقاتلين الاكراد من
اقليم اي كردستان تحديدا من سنجار اضافه
الى ان التنسيق حول ضبط الحدود والتعاون
المشترك بين كل طبعا من تركيا والعراق
خاصه في الجانب الاستخباراتي وتبادل
المعلومات على الحدود بين البلدين وشدد
السودان على انه لن يسمح بان تتحول اراضي
العراق الى مصدر تهديد لدول الجوار
المباحثات شهدت تناول
الملف الامني نرتبط مع تركيا
بحدود طويله
تجاوز 300 كيلو متر
وهنا اود ان اؤكد ان العراق ملتزم بعدم
السماح لاستخدام اراضيه كمنطلق
للاعتداء على تركيا
والامن امن المنطقه هو امن واحد لا يتجزا
ومن خلال التعاون الاستخباراتي وتبادل
معلومات بالتاكيد سوف نحل هذه المشاكل
الامنيه بعيدا عن استخدام العنف
وبما يحافظ على امن وسياده العراق التي
نحرص على تحقيقها وان لا تؤثر على علاقتنا
وتوجهاتنا الكبيره
والجاده لتطوير العلاقه بين العراق وتركيا